you are looking live tonight at new york
city at the 9 11 memorial and tomorrow
marks 20 years since those terrorist
attacks nearly 3 000 people died when
four planes were hijacked two crashed
into the twin towers in new york one
crashed into the pentagon and passengers
on the fourth plane stopped the
hijackers on flight 93 and for years
people from all across the country have
visited the national memorial there in
shanksville pennsylvania to pay their
respects matt alvarez is live in
shanksville tonight and takes us on a
tour of what you can expect to see and
also experience on that site good
evening
well good evening tens of thousands of
people visit the flight 93 national
memorial every year and the national
park service says this year there will
be many more visitors
as you begin your visit to the hollowed
grounds of the flight 93 national
memorial you'll first be met by the
tower of voices it's made up of chimes
each representing a voice on board
flight 93. the tower itself creates this
incredible sound and when you experience
it it's very humbling
and you're thinking of what happened
that day on september 11. from here
you'll take a two mile trek to the
flight 93 national memorial visitors
center so this black sidewalk pierces
through the two portal walls of the
visitor center
those portal walls are helping focus
your eyesight towards the trajectory of
flight 93 which would have been straight
ahead and above us a learning center is
just a few hundred feet away so we have
three recorded phone calls that visitors
can listen to that were left on
answering machines from passenger and
crew members that made phone calls
aboard flight 93. a short walk from the
learning center is an overlook where you
can see the crash site debris field and
the wall of names the names of each hero
who took down the terrorists on
september 11 2001.
so the flight path here will end
just there beyond the wooden gate this
wooden gate is the ceremonial gate it's
a hand-hewn hemlock gate made with 40
angles one for each of the passenger and
crew members this is a really incredible
place wally reed is visiting from texas
this is his first time at the flight 93
national memorial it brings you back to
that day and
all the emotions of that day
and the pride that we have in our
country and the pride that we have in
those people that were on this flight 93
too and what they did for our country
the flight 93 national memorial grounds
for healing closure education and
respect for those who stood against
terrorism and gave their lives for
countless others
and the park service says they've seen
quite the influx of international
visitors as well to the memorial it's a
sure sign that this memorial will be
around for generations
to come and denise i understand that a
teacher from las vegas was actually on
the flight that hit the pentagon back on
september 11 2001. uh yeah matt you're
referring to barbara edwards there she
was back to remember this morning at
palo verde high school where she was a
teacher and i'm sure there are
memorials like that for everyone who was
on board so matt thanks so much for that
report tonight